ايضا هناك صمت تخرقه طقطقه مفاتيح او
اصابع كل حين وعزله تامه فيما وصف بل وصف
باكثر السجون شرا هذه بعض كوابيس سجناء
مروا في سجن لفورتوفو الروسي الذي يحتجز
فيه مراسل صحيفه وولز
بتهمه التجسس طبعا سجن لفورتوفو تم بناؤه
على شكل حرف k كسجن عسكري شرقي موسكو عام
المنشاه تتكون من مئات الزنزانات الصغيره
المصممه بعنايه لجعل المعتقلين يشعرون
بعزله وانقطاع تام عن العالم الخارجي خلال
الحقبه السوفيتيه اصبح مكانا سيء السمعه
يساق اليه المنشقون وايضا غيرهم من
المساجين هناك ايضا يجري الحراس ممارسات
تهدف الى التاثير على السجناء نفسيا فهم
يمنعونهم من رؤيه او سماع اي شخص حتى
زملائهم من السجناء الاخرين صحيفه وول
ستريت جون الاوضحت ان الحراس يقومون
بدوريات ويقرعون مفاتيحهم معا للاشاره الى
ان نزيلا تتم مرافقته لغرفه استجواب فيما
اخرون يطقطقون اصابعهم في الممرات ليصيبوا
المساجين بالجنون ووفق معتقلين سابقين من
المحتمل ان يكون مراسل الصحيفه في الحجر
الصحيح حاليا وهو اجراء يستمر تقريبا
اسبوعين للكشف عن التهاب الكبد وامراض
اخرى
[موسيقى]